welcome to this video playing FM card
start from Thailand jury kopinski living
on Phuket Thailand ok let's see to 385
yeah and well if I'm not mistaken this
video is going to be released on on them
on New Year's Eve so I wish you all a
good happy new year oh that's wrong well
New Year's Eve celebration is what I
what I wishing you'd have good ones have
a good time and I'm trying to continue
my my winning streak here in five minute
blitz 12 out of 12 is the result of the
recent games and playing this somewhat
is somewhat yeah I don't know how to
call it the modern the modern again well
I don't really feel that much at home
but it is interesting leads to
interesting positions now I'm putting
big pressure on the fire in d5 was a
somewhat strange move in my book it
exposes the center quite considerably
and I mean the best that white can
probably achieve is to sometimes take on
c6 and this is just a good Sicilian 94
runs into an gap probably in to see 5
but maybe also taking on d5 and Knight
b6 can be good I'm actually intending to
play Knight b6 next to put more pressure
on this may be also rook c8 is a good
strengthening move
yeah yet up not bad not easy for wide to
find a plenty i think t5 was a little
bit early
yeah travel of trail that's a good run
would be fun to exactly get 225 it for
the new year all this is recorded a
little bit earlier than when it is
released yelling so wait I can take your
form but that's not really great iam we
should be foil his knight c6 Bishop your
form I don't like to do that especially
considering that no I'm threatening you
are threatening Knight takes e4 anyway
and he has no great way to to play f3 is
really ugly stuff this is like a perfect
Sicilian and this guy's not even an e4
player i started deformed i have some
some ideas here i can just play d 5
which is a good thing actually
strategically speaking swapping d again
sleep on i can also play for a night
coming to see for some times e 5 and d5
is an idea but this this looks a little
bit unrealistic IAM push-up h6 may be in
the mix Maddie five it is it is
strategically good but it's a little bit
on the boring side
maybe 494 okay give me this Bishop
player I'll take it okay so d5 now on
this just maybe runs into an awkward pin
on the divan I mean maybe Justin back
here intending well there Bishop takes
the 3 s's the kind of a is risky
business it is yeah 95 he s maybe f4 I
really am
don't like to trade the bishop is that
way to avoid that
95 their form
as Lucas exposed I don't know this is
this is I mean I have no problem but it
looked far better a couple of moves ago
I probably made some kind of mistake I
don't know when I would at which point
exactly oh I didn't even think about
this at all that this is possible no I'm
not sure how good it is but I should
have seen the movie he's six 93 94 let's
check this
9b 696 runs into Queen d4 check ok let's
try to get rid of this annoyed check
yeah you ready 5 know is is quite ok I
think shouldn't be a problem I have this
nice square on c3 which is very
important I'm going to just hack this
off and now put this rook down you can
go to c6 but this rook is not going away
ever and what is the screen doing efore
maybe as an attacking idea efore takes
rook h3 this kind of stuff but among
this diagonal yeah this is a problem so
f5 to step 5 i wonder if i can try to
win this porn actually with this
we have seven ones in 298 that's not
good but I can take this right 493 as
well
93 rookie three wasn't clear to me time
morning would love to trade quince am
absolutely love that can I get this in
check i have i have this okay check
the test it doesn't have good squares
this rukan yeah intending 92 with Queen
g1 meet this is this is quite strong if
I get it in oops I think I get it in
almost like a yes is check only 93 is
also quite nice to to play I don't want
to trade queens here with him almost
check and sitting on a checkmate but I
had to play him I had to play a move
check terrible they porno rather be porn
I don't believe that I screwed this up
unbelievable from this totally outplayed
them check check check I will continue
this year not after the start of the
game check ok Jack I'm winning this
after roll-ups check picking up the
piece of sim
check white forfeits on time oh wow okay
this is a serious of wins that seems to
be destined to hold even from this
position yeah okay it was it wasn't
totally undeserved I mean Hayes is like
totally busted after 92 but do I ways
what did i do here deform has the nice
evaluation of minus 27 which is quite a
lot it doesn't even have pieces for this
27 it's probably I made somewhere but
why is it is it the maid I don't see it
yet they have three am breaking through
yeah that's made threatening this
actually and something like this he only
has the only has one check somewhere and
then I'm meeting with Queen Queen f2 or
Quinn g3 or whatever some something like
this checkmate is the maid yeah I only
found that and I will I kind of knew
that I shouldn't trade but hmm you have
to play and yet I really made it tricky
this stuff here and now he has to see
for business and it's not clear on I
even lost the tempo here by and here
wide wins this is check it's just too
much the B point is running unbelievable
yeah okay
check it was continuing because of the
pawns but there are multiple ways to win
here it's funny enough for kinky to
still wins this losers of course but it
was a matter of seconds knight c6 is
still winning him I go here he has roomy
62 to stop it but we both didn't have
any time yeah what again but I wanted to
keep this winning streak and it it did
it did I did hold up whoo okay well
thanks for watching